So let's see if we can use
load links to our conditional
to implement a lock function.
The lock function takes
a reference to variable lockvar,
and then, in assembler, and
then it will do something like this.
Put 1 in R1, load the current value
of lockvar into R2 using a load link,
then store R1 into lockvar using
store conditional, so the idea
is that we load the current value of
the lock and then we store a 1 there.
The question for you is what do we put
here to complete this lock function
in a way that works correctly?
That is, if we leave this function we
know that we have acquired the lock and
we are the only ones that did so.
The first option for
where the question mark is,
is simply to do a branch on
branch on equals 0, R1, trylock.
The second choice here is branch
on equals 0, R2, trylock.
The third choice is to do branch
on not equal 0, R2, trylock.
And then branch on equals 0,
link, trylock.
The fourth option is
branch on not equal 0,
R2, trylock, and
then branch on equals 0, R1, trylock.
And the fifth, final option is to do
branch on not equal 0 in R2 to trylock.
Followed by branch on not equal 0,
link, trylock.
Select which one of these five is
the correct thing to put here.